nobel peace prize for it went to the
world food program prix nobel 2001 au
programme alimentaire mondial pour sa
lutte contre la faim pour la paix et
contre l'utilisation de la faim comme
armes de guerres et de conflits
voici le pam en actions au soudan du sud
en février dernier au dessus de new york
la mission larguer des cartons d'huile
de cuisson des sacs de céréales
ce n'est qu'une zone de guerre il y en a
d'autres en syrie au yémen en
afghanistan
opérant par hélicoptère dos d'éléphants
et de chameaux
le pam est la plus grande opération
humanitaire du monde puisqu'on estime à
près de 700 millions de personnes
presque une sur dix les populations qui
souffrent de sous-alimentation chronique
souvent les femmes et les enfants
le président du pam n'en revient pas ce
prix dit il revient à la famille du pam
tous ceux qui sont dans les endroits les
plus difficiles les plus complexes les
conflits les climats extrêmes
c'est une des raisons données par le
comité nobel de norvège pour récompenser
le pam les agences des nations unies au
moins de soutiens ces temps ci avec le
brésil les etats-unis qui sont à
l'occasion critique de la coopération
internationale ainsi que le populisme
dans les pays plus petits fondée en 1961
le programme alimentaire mondial a
assisté l'an dernier 97 millions de
personnes dans 88 pays et distribué 15
milliards de rations il a son siège à
genève
le pam est financé à 100% par des
contributions volontaires soit 8
milliards de dollars en 2000
un montant record mais qui risque de
diminuer alors que les besoins vont
augmenter c'est la douzième fois que le
prix nobel de la paix consacre l'onu une
de ces agences ou une personnalité qui
est lié plus que tout autre lorient jean
michel leprince a du canada à montréal
[Musique]